That's enough HTML elements for now. I want to talk about the
structure of an actual HTML document really quick before we move
on. Now, what we've been seeing before is just little mark
up. We've been seeing things like this. You know little tags, a
few little simple tags. But an actual complete HTML document has
quite a bit more in it. Here's a whole lot more
HTML. Let's take this piece by piece but this is what
a complete HTML document looks like. First we have the DOCTYPE. And
this is what kind of, of HTML this is. This
string right here is, used to be a lot more
complex. If you were to Google for DOCTYPES you would
see a lot of different answers here. But now that
we're using HTML5, it has a nice clean simple doc
type, which is just the string HTML. Very simple, okay.
Then we have a tag. This is the basically the,
the opening HTML tag and the closing HTML tag. This surrounds
the entire rest of the document. That's all it does,
is it surrounds the entire document. Now I've got this
other tag here, the head. This part of the document
has kind of metadata and, and another random stuff. If
you were to include JavaScript and CSS, CSS, remember we
talked about it as the filing sort of stuff, that
would be included in the head section. Now we also
have this little tag here, the title, and this is the
title of the page. This is what would appear in
the top of your browser window, or in, in your
browser tab, this string right here. Then we have the
body tag, and the body tag is the actual contents
of the document. And basically, we've been, we've been working
just in the body tag in this lesson. And for
most of this course, we're really just going to be focusing
on generating the content that fits between the body tags.
It's all this other stuff is important and you'll see it,
and we'll be, you know, we'll sending over the wire. But it
doesn't change very often and, you know, it's pretty simple, but it
is pretty important for it to be there. All of the interesting
stuff though happens between the body tags. Okay, let's take another
view at HTML documents, they have a structure that can visualized like
this. An HTML document this whole thing has a head section and
that's where we have our title, references to any CSS files, and
Java script files, and that sort of stuff. And then we
have the body section and this is where the actual contents of
the document, the stuff that you see on the screen. This is
where that comes from. And in this course where mostly going to focus
on this part of an HTML document. Just the body section
and there's a lot of content that can go in there. Well,
we'll, you know, discuss briefly, you know, CSS and JavaScript and how
they fit into everything. But, for the most part, we're going to be
generating the contents, the body, of, of an HTML document.